now
since the first model T's began rolling
off the assembly line Americans have
fallen deeply in love with cars
there is personalized clothes or tattoos
part of the stories we tell about
ourselves
Hollywood knows how we feel about them
whether they are taking us on an
adventure
or on a vacation or even to the future
if you talk to them
I can't take another blow like that we
give them names
you raise them let's go for a little
ride we wreck them but mostly we adore
them where's your garden which is why I
just had to do a story about people who
steal them
on average every 36 seconds a car is
stolen here in the United States it's
big money
and it's often done by somebody just
like this
[Music]
oh my God that took like less than five
seconds
okay this is it
[Applause]
yeah this is insane
how many cars you think are here tonight
usually we'll get five thousand or more
cards seriously 100 I mean like
Gathering of so many cars the donuts
none of that is legal right
no comment no comments
who do you think are stolen
thousands
I've reported on a lot of illegal
activities but I've never done a story
about stolen cars
I was tipped off however that these late
night meetups would be a good place to
start digging
like most of these folks I followed a
trail of social media posts to this
location in New York City
[Music]
it was announced last minute so that the
police wouldn't be able to shut it down
this underground car culture is the real
life version of The Fast and the Furious
flying in the air
the popularity of these events has
exploded with the success of the
franchise
but not all attendees can afford a fancy
car
so these meetups have become a popular
playground for joyriders
I do so do you guys know anyone who
steals cards uh no nope no I don't
personally know anyone now if you did
would you tell me
no probably not after Decades of decline
in the US auto theft spiked in 2020 to
the tune of nearly 900 000 cars
have you ever stolen a car so yeah
um my first car stole is when I was 16.
I wind up talking to a guy we're calling
Anthony
how easy is it to look for
it's easy as quick in and
outer so a lot of people ask me to go
buy these cars and they pay me lots of
money
I learned that the old toe and go is one
of several unsophisticated yet popular
ways to steal a car
[Music]
if you're a car thief sometimes you've
got the right tools a dark colored tow
truck backs up to a house and steals
this car while the owner slept
sometimes you need a gun my life lost
before my eyes I literally was like this
is it and sometimes your targets are
just not careful enough
this is surveillance video of a car left
warming up that was stolen last week
about half of stolen cars in the United
States end up back in the hands of their
rightful owners that leaves over four
billion dollars worth of unrecovered
cars that wind up everywhere from used
car lots to chop shops
and you see everybody running to their
cars and leaving look it's good
[Music]
oh wow
how old are you now I'm 20 now how much
money do you have you made from the Cars
you've stolen so far see like a little
under 60 000
stripping them down mainly reports on
the solar and east coast and that's not
doing it often Anthony tells me that
it's harder for the cops to trace the
parts of a stolen car
but the thieves who make the big money
must take a bigger risk selling the
whole car intact
and there's people making hundreds of
thousands on nice cars nice nice cars
you sell them there's a whole car
because maybe they're not going to trace
the VIN and some third world country
it turns out there's an underground
supply chain of stolen cars exported
overseas that's one of the most
lucrative smuggling routes in the game
so how exactly does a two-ton object
packed with anti-theft technology
completely disappear
where does it end up and who's pulling
the strings on such a complicated
operation
that's exactly what I want to find out
okay so this is it about two minutes
from the Newark Airport I'm actually
thinking stayed at this hotel before I
learned that one hub for these
International car theft Rings is based
just a few miles down the road in Newark
New Jersey
oh this is it
definitely
for a long time the city was known as
the stolen car capital of the world
hi Mariana
number one I heard how you want to be
called for years number one was part of
an operation known for moving millions
of dollars worth of luxury Vehicles
overseas we ran a few cars by you and
you said this is one that you used to
regularly you've stole how many of these
particular cars do you think you stole
okay I can't even count it's maybe
thousands wait thousands just of this
make and model yeah
was this one of your favorites no no it
was my favorite money is my favorite
eventually his luck ran out
over the course of a two-year
investigation called operation jacked
Authority seized hundreds of cars valued
at over 12 million dollars and evicted
more than 50 car ring members including
number one
when I heard that he'd been released
from prison I managed to track him down
he was reluctant to talk on camera at
first because he told me he's out of the
game
but eventually he agreed to show us a
few
of his old tricks
so I was in the front by the rearview
mirror
okay
and then I gotta go in the back
all right I see it
all right I love you bro
who is that he's one of the best at top
uh doing this yeah what were you doing
tracking device it's like I won't start
keeps them from being able to find the
car of course we don't want to advertise
too much but there's something over
there in the rearview mirror and then
there's something in the back and that
disables the GPS yeah and every car has
not every car all the majority cars have
a tracking device it needed different
places so when you called him right now
all you said was a model on the make of
the car and he immediately knew he knows
where everything got does he think that
you're actually trying to steal a car
yeah did he say anything no no he just
automatically gave me the information I
needed because it could have been
critical you have no time to waste yo
where you at what you got none of your
business I need your help number one
insists that cops have only cracked the
tip of the iceberg the big players are
still very much in the game the car
business is a multi-billion dollar a
year business do you think that people
will want their money to stop I ask if
he's able to connect me to any active
players but he tells me it's too risky
people want to kill me to answer
questions
unfortunately in my experience luck
doesn't open many doors
[Music]
I need to find someone who trusts me
enough
to show me how this racket really works
hey we're a couple blocks away like a
minute away
okay I decide to tap an old connection
from the drug trafficking underworld
he tells me that when his dealers head
out for a job they'll rent a stolen car
for a couple hours from a crew of car
thieves
he's managed to set up a meeting with
one he calls fittingly klepto
how many times you do this you've always
been a little nervous
worst thing you can do anyways
we can take exploded around for the two
cars that they're asking for on the list
okay what cars are those oh okay now
we're looking into a Mercedes and a
Nissan we got to be careful because this
time yeah people come out sometimes
shooting that is
yeah you see it there you see them
[Music]
the trash cans are right there
actually taking out the trash can
from the front of the car so you can
move the car
okay he's doing it he's doing it right
now look look he's doing it
oh my god did you see that
okay he's doing it he's doing it right
now look look
oh my god did you see that
oh my God that took like less than five
seconds
what did he do he did something to the
handle and then I made a noise and it
opened
do you see this he just put the window
down and went like this and waved
[Music]
that was crazy
oh my God I don't even I'm like totally
discombobulated I don't know what
and now they're going super fast and I'm
supposed to keep up with them
now we're just driving behind a stolen
car
[Music]
and they're parking right here
so that was insane gone on 60 seconds in
your case it was gone in five seconds
exactly that's a lie but I saw you had a
little trouble with the handle our keys
don't open car locks
how did you open the lock then uh can't
really tell you that little secret
okay and then once you're inside the
ignition starts yes it's a program key
you can program the key to any damn call
since most modern car
virgin key fob is the car's VIN number
and all car thieves need is a Savvy but
corrupt mechanic
and so you did your first one I know
you're in a bit of a rush you have to go
do your second what's the second person
Mercedes so it's a Mercedes you know
what's somewhere in this neighborhood
what is this neighborhood like it's uh a
lot of white people man and you're
talking about multi-million dollar homes
here it's okay you know they cheat a lot
of people so everybody teach people rich
people cheat people why not let's cheat
does it ever cross your mind how are
they going to feel when they wake up in
the morning and they don't see their
cars they ain't gonna suffer and they're
not gonna lose anything but a damn car
it ain't nothing
stupid money for the bank insurance
covers your money but insurance claims
go up for everybody we all actually at
the end of the year they end up paying
for cars of course of course it doesn't
make me a bad guy
every time he was putting the gun on me
I was like I was like no please don't
don't please him because he was like
booming boom like that he was just
hitting me with the gun it was horrible
[Music]
foreign
ER that jumps out and takes care of my
corner any cop that's coming in whatever
I already know the whistle he makes
like I'm a person that drives me right
here he's in a 10-up truck he Parks away
from me and then of course I got my
other little buddy over there who Parks
a little bit further just you know of
course of course he signals him that guy
signals him I gotta have at least two
black silver girl because
no no no no no I'm not trying to go to
jail again and you were shot at before
Oh plenty of times
oh my God what if the people come out
this makes me so nervous
oh my God I feel so bad for the whoever
so I have a car this is
insane and I've seen a lot of crazy
what starts to come into focus is I'm
talking to klepto is the organizational
structure of these International
operations
Crews of Thieves like kleptos are the
bottom of the pyramid once they steal a
car I'm told they want to get rid of it
as soon as possible
but how and to whom that's what I'm
itching to uncover the next levels of
the pyramid
you dropped off the cars today at the
parking lot what happened to those cars
well right now the guys are going to go
clean them up and then they're going to
go what do you mean by clean them up
that's my expertise after years of
success running a crew of Thieves
klepto's career in stolen cars has
actually progressed he's now also
working in a position that's known as
defense how did you learn how to do that
since I was a little kid working at body
shops you know family members still need
other cars you learn trick the treat the
in the operation
the job to handle the logistics of
laundering a stolen car to disguise the
fact that it's stolen and then what
happens after that
um the low jacks so they won't track
them the GPS yes so you have somebody
who knows how to do that yes the GPS
remove it and then what happens after
that we change the numbers the VIN
numbers we have another person who knows
how to change pin numbers yeah the
vehicle identification number or vin is
a unique lifetime ID born from the
moment a car rolls out of the factory
klepto doesn't reveal how they change
the vins but once a new VIN number is
installed they'll Forge new title and
registration documents to match
and how much you get paid per car so it
depends on the car like so the Mercedes
for tonight about 30 000 30 000 yeah at
each step in the process klepto pays off
the players involved
it cost me four four thousand dollars
for the key yeah three thousand to each
of the thieves two thousand to the VIN
forger one thousand to the wheel man who
disables the GPS
so it's that profitable that you can
still make money while paying all these
people yes I can meaning for a car like
the Mercedes after paying off the crew
he'll Bank around twelve thousand
dollars
it's sold to the wire that's asking for
it they send it into the Container you
never see it again
the car transfers hands to the final
player on the U.S side of the network
the shipper
you can't just put this in your luggage
sneak it to another country I meet back
up with number one who I know has
experience at this level of the
operation over the years he says he's
made these drops many many times
I don't know exact count but over a
couple thousand where were the
containers going different countries do
you know where exactly
number one agrees to drive me to the
location where he'd rendezvous with the
shippers but warns me that this handoff
is still the most dangerous in the
process
well here with this car is parked in
front of the gate yeah that's where we
used to pull up driving there and put
the car in the containers
so the containers would be here waiting
they said 10 o'clock at night then we'll
meet them there at 10 o'clock at night
any one of these trucks could be in the
process of doing that right now oh my
God
we have no way of knowing if thieves
will be packing these containers with
stolen cars tonight but if they are it's
definitely not safe to stick around see
our car still here dangerous like that
because we don't know exactly what they
do right and if they see us around with
cameras exactly you don't ask questions
if somebody standing there with M16
AK-47s they were armed the people
running the business weren't you scared
well the first time I did it yet I press
number one about who are the kingpins
these car rings but he either doesn't
know or won't say
so I do what any good journalist does I
follow the money
to the port in Newark where there's one
final hurdle standing in the Smuggler's
way
oh that's a nice one oh
oh that's a nice one that's a beautiful
Jeep right there wow pop the other door
wow so is this possibly a stolen car yes
possibly good chance absolutely it's a
very good chance a very good chance two
in there two Mercedes-Benz oh there's it
there it is Mercedes brands in front
there's a Jeep here brand new 350. WoW
brand new they're both brand new cars
so here we have a couple of ships the
U.S Customs and Border protection's main
focus is to intercept Contraband coming
into the United States
not heading outbound
[Music]
it's row after row after row here
thousands of containers this is the
largest port on the East Coast he
estimates that they're only able to
inspect a small fraction of cars leaving
the United States so that's a VIN number
this is the bin number right here on the
desk which is good news for the car
theft Rings I've been investigating it's
coming up as a positive positive what we
got a positive stolen yeah
so it's immediate you can tell right
away if you look inside you still see
there's a cell phone charger inside so
you can see someone still the personal
belongings of the person whose vehicle
this belong to right out the driveway
right out the driveway yeah so there's a
car like this now that you found that
it's stolen and you know eventually who
the owner was doesn't go back to the
owner or what happens well the insurance
had already made the payout so this
usually goes back to the insurance
company I kind of feel bad for the owner
of the car stolen yeah and the fact that
we're all standing on top of his car
right now
once a vessel departs for international
waters the cars that flip through have a
much much Slimmer chance for Recovery
this was all the same container four
cars ending with this the Escalade they
have it packed with personal effects
there could be guns in here there could
be all sorts of different contraband
these three cars were in one container
if you look you got two of them or
Salvage claws they're smashed up and
then we had to see a 2021 Land Rover
right there it's a flag for me why
something it's out of place you're going
to put a 2021 layer over and with two
wrecks where it might get damaged
how many cars are exported from here
every year approximately 400 000 cars a
year that thirty thousand cars a month
oh you go through all of them or how
does that work it's impossible to go
through all of them what was found last
year was 310 stolen cars out of this
port I would like to think
that's all of them 310 but that's not
true
it's really like finding a needle in a
haystack so who's actually making money
with all this well everybody involved is
making money who's making the most
my guess is it's overseas it hadn't
actually occurred to me before that the
real money makers of this operation
aren't here in the US
if there's truly that much money to be
made overseas it begs the question who's
atop this pyramid and will I be able to
find them
how soon after a car is stolen does it
end up in a container like this if
somebody's stealing it let's call it New
York
put in a container next couple hours
it's it's on Terminal ready to be the
party it could be that fast it could be
the same day next day kind of thing
could be that day
they steal them from outside
have them trucked into Jersey
put them in a container here
and out they go to a number of different
destinations
[Music]
one of the most popular destinations for
stolen cars shipped from the east coast
is 5 000 miles across the Atlantic Ocean
in West Africa
[Music]
in a developing Nation owning a car can
be synonymous with entry into the middle
class
[Music]
nowhere is that more evidence than Ghana
home to one of the fastest growing
economies on the planet
walk around the capital Accra and you'll
feel the energy opportunity is in the
air
[Music]
the going economy it doesn't mean that
our people are making some amount of
money they would want to have a better
life if there's no way people want to
have a better life without all in cars
so it's a huge industry here in Ghana
yes I mean we're developing country
everybody wants to drive their car we'll
get out of the university the next thing
they're thinking about is a car Peter as
we'll call him is a local investigative
journalist who tells me that Rising
incomes have opened the door to New
Black markets like stolen cars
what would happen if people found out
you were helping us up
don't mean that somebody puts in an end
to your life is it that dangerous it's
very dangerous that's the
foreignty should be investigated in the
first place
so you think actually that a lot of the
people that buy these cars don't know
that they're stolen cars
the action is killing any local industry
the vast majority of cars in Ghana are
imported in fact they're the number one
imported item in the country people want
to have more exotic lives if you meet an
old school mate right they're able to
charge you by the car you drive so
everybody wants to drive a good car
whether they are cheap or you know um
stolen stalling and that's why black
market industry as cars is booming here
so can you tell me more or less how the
process works so the cars arrive to find
the people they are getting this from
these Fun Boys what are they called
fraud boards the guys involved in this
car business they're called the Frog
points
and everybody knows about them
everybody knows about them and is it all
sort of the same Syndicate then that's
all it depends on the sort of Click you
belong to Peter says he can connect me
to a contact who's inside their
tight-knit circles
but it's unclear what role this person
plays
[Music]
there's a guy who's somehow involved in
this car business who's agreed to talk
to us so we're driving to what might be
his house or his business I'm not sure
the sun is actually going down really
fast it's going to get dark soon you
don't want to get stuck in these unknown
roads in the middle of the night
well that didn't happen
okay I'll go out first
little did I know that I had just
stepped inside the nerve center the
entire operation
[Music]
I learned that there are criminal groups
behind the stolen car game here in Ghana
are known as fraud boys
[Music]
I wanted to meet them face to face and
find out who's pulling the strings
and if you can put your mask up again
sorry
[Music]
so how do you want to be called
Shadow Walker is that your online name
yeah
in an apartment on the outskirts of
Accra I connect with one of these
Infamous fraud boys
what is it exactly that you do well what
I'd write it is is
your bank accounts credit card
information and what I found was the
heart of the entire operation so you go
to a backup okay and dark web is not the
place that you can go there it's on a
Mac browser everything is also Anonymous
using an anonymous browser called Tor he
accesses the dark web and logs into
underground hacker forums where almost
any product is listed for sale oh
cocaine Colombian cocaine
this is a credit card information
oh somebody's selling this they are
selling if you've ever received an email
from your favorite retailer apologizing
for a huge data breach a massive Cyber
attack affecting nearly 50 million more
than 100 million Capital One credit
cards it's possible that your identity
and credit card information is being
sold at an underground hacker Forum just
like this is there tons of these for
sale of course
what for a pittance paid anonymously in
cryptocurrency criminals can buy your
credit card info and load it onto a
fresh card
and then what do you do with all that
information
somebody to give him credit card
information we'll take care of it in the
U.S yes with a stolen credit card and a
fake ID these guys can walk into any car
rental location and drive off with a car
that will wind up 5 000 miles away on
the streets of Accra
no broken windows no fake key fobs no
carjacking clean and efficient
it's right about now that I truly grasp
who I'm standing next to he isn't some
entry-level page but rather a
technological wizard who binds the whole
operation together and he has one more
trick up his sleeve so this is a car
let's say coming from New York to Ghana
yes
the import fee yes
import duties can cost up to 20 percent
of the market value of a car so a brand
new Range Rover valued at a hundred
thousand would be taxed 20 grand so it's
my dream outdoor attack
so you can hack into the custom service
at the harbor yeah
everything I'm Blown Away by their
methods in addition to their American
contacts who steal cars the
old-fashioned way these sophisticated
Ghanaian operators have found other more
ingenious ways to swipe our beloved
rides
it all points to the Kingpin at the top
of the pyramid and I want to meet
whoever that is face to face
do you know anyone who's involved in
other parts of the car business
foreign
and after some persistence a contact
finally leads me to the Breakthrough
I've been searching for
a meeting with a mastermind
we're actually very close to the
location seems like it's a really nice
neighborhood here right it's a bunch of
big houses
okay
is this someone you should trust
like this
[Music]
hi
um thank you for meeting us
um what would what is this
what car is this this is a Mercedes-Benz
C250 it's a nice car
and it's from it's stolen
uh yeah I just came from the states
do you know where in the states I have
no idea understood where it's coming
from
like many of these underworld First
Dates
the vibus tense suspicious
he has to be called Ivan and I can sense
that he's sizing me up when did this
arrive in Ghana two three months ago two
three months ago and do you have people
interested already so this happens to be
in a garage so oh so this is in a car
dealership
so it's one of several there but this is
what I have available at the moment can
I go inside yeah sure be my guest it's
so crazy to think that just a couple of
months ago this car was in the US
belonging to somebody else
what other cars came in the same sort of
shipment as this one it comes in the
consignment of like three four five six
the mood starts to relax
feel like he's warming up to me he tells
me that his group is one of the bigger
operations in Accra and that they buy
stolen cars in bulk shipments how much
did you pay for this one this one yeah
do you pay what you can taste like um I
know but how much I just want to get a
sense
but ultimately he plays koi in spite of
my efforts to get more information from
him he ends up refusing to answer most
of my questions
[Music]
have I opened this
so I decide to poke around and see if I
can learn anything more about this
mystery car
oh and this is because the GPS has been
cut out I guess maybe there might be a
reason why they took it off wow so check
this out this is tampered with
what's in here
[Music]
is this the Red Lobster
do you have Red Lobster here no oh my
God Virginia let me see
I will I will so we're close to knowing
that at least the person was in Virginia
I have no idea
he doesn't want to really show that I
won't say the city in Virginia there was
also a city in Virginia I didn't say
that
[Music]
just a minute
maybe it's somebody who wants to buy
this car sure definitely should be a
buyer so I can make a quick question
before I could get what I wanted a
confession a tell-all interview about
the whole stolen car operation from one
of the big players
stolen Mercedes-Benz that got here just
a few months ago from the US I'm dying
to know more about this car's history
who owned it do they miss it and do they
have any idea where their car is now
back in America I get some answers about
this mystery car from detective Paula
Brunetto with the Connecticut State
Police she's been investigating car
theft rings for decades yeah I looked at
the event and um so it's from a 2014
Mercedes-Benz that was involved in a
serious crash which caused it to be a
total loss no one's going to drive this
car you're telling me that you saw this
car in Africa being driven and it was
not smashed up right no it was a
beautiful Mercedes-Benz so the car you
saw was probably stolen with a VIN but
the VIN number from this one that was
totaled in a horrific crash in Florida
stolen car's VIN number would be flagged
by authorities but a totaled carsvin
wouldn't so there's no way that the VIN
on that car that I saw was the real VIN
number for their car I very very much
doubt that the car you saw in Africa was
the same exact car the VIN number on
that car was Riven and is being driven
around in another country with some
clever coordination the fraud boys can
swap out the VIN of a stolen car with
the same make and model that they pick
up at a salvage auction
so once it comes up clean from the pot
there's nothing to worry about there's
nothing to worry about it raises a
question about who's really calling the
shots in these operations and who's
making most of the money
I needed to get some answers so I asked
Ivan if he'd be willing to meet me again
in our first meeting he didn't divulge
much information
and it's rare to get a follow-up meeting
with a top dog but I'm hoping it will
happen I know there's a lot more he's
not telling me
you should be told to wait in this uh
parking lot by this church
is where he's supposed to meet us I
wasn't sure if he'd show up
but now it's go time
[Music]
I managed to convince one of the top
fraud boys in the stolen car game in
Ghana to meet me for a rare second
interview
I'm hoping this will be my chance for a
tell-all to see the stolen car world
through his eyes
and here's another club and here you go
more fancy cars we've got more Mercedes
he takes me to an area known for
nightlife in a crop a place where he and
fellow fraud boys come to woo potential
clients Mercedes Mercedes are big here
Maserati do you think that's stolen it's
possible most of these guys are
Australia really yeah most of the boys
come here to hang out what's up guys
that are into the business now the
cooling car business
didn't have some family Generations have
made money
how much money do you think we're
talking about millions of dollars
because the business has become the
competition who own the richest cars and
that proves your connections that proves
you have a strong contact up until this
point I had assumed that the American
criminals were the masterminds of these
operations and that West Africa proved
to be a useful place to offload their
merchandise
is to make available most expensive cars
that you can think of so who's making
most of the money
you have to sell it make the money but
he's finally spilling the beans and as
it turns out it's actually the opposite
so you make most of Life yeah yeah I
make most of the money
the fraud boys are not just the buyers
they're the masterminds of the operation
and have found willing American
criminals to do their dirty work
the chain is sort of separated so that
you don't know what happens
right and that protects the whole
Enterprise yeah that's how it is it's
guys like Ivan in West Africa who are
actually at the top of the pyramid in
these International car theft rings
everybody wants cheap stuff in Africa so
even rich people buy yes rich people buy
cheap stuff so if you have a luxury car
that's selling for like sixty thousand
dollars that the market is about 120 000
that's a better deal but that wouldn't
that raise Flex a car that's a third
it's written there for last year but at
least it would raise some sort of
Suspicion right the for the buyer
wouldn't they think for a second or
maybe this how would they know it
everybody knows so it goes really deep
this business yeah it's not just about
stolen cars we have the mix of these
businesses the fraud bodies like the
name suggests are always on the lookout
for the
Trinity the next scam you know the dark
world is where everything happens right
I'm doing a business I want to make
profit out of whatever it is their
tentacles stretch into all sorts of
criminal activities money laundering
romance scams gold fraud they're part of
a growing Syndicate that's way bigger
than I'd imagined you feel sorry for the
people that woke up one morning and they
don't have their cars outside their
houses so I'm looking at home can solve
the car and make money
I'm not looking at how the other guy
feels okay but isn't there a little part
of you that thinks the poor guy who
doesn't have a car maybe he like saved
all his money to buy this car somebody
crying about his car then I'll feel
these but since I'm not hearing that to
cry
it's far away so I don't feel guilty in
any way with so much distance between
the steel and the a cell it's not hard
to imagine feeling disconnected
he might not feel guilty
but others do
you ever feel bad for the people uh yes
sometimes I ask myself so what do this
money is for someone's son celebration
yeah but somebody would do the same
thing to me they're not gonna feel bad
for me
you go you end up in prison you ask
yourself was it worth it and it wasn't
do you feel bad at all no
I need the money just probably better
more than worse than they do
no matter how you feel about the
justifications for stealing these cars
the truth is as long as the orders keep
coming from this side of the Atlantic
the entire underground pipeline is bound
to keep thriving
there's no real deterrent to stop doing
this right yeah it's illegal from the
states not from Martin
how many cars you estimate are being
stolen every day in the city oh hundreds
hundreds I mean we don't just leave them
here they're all across the country oh
yeah
if you just get a Bentley for the price
of a Honda Accord
really good it's a billion dollars a
year business
all your money is profit
y'all give me a good reason why you
think it'll stop
[Music]